nous allons vivre ensemble et bien ces
résultats lui tienne président de la
république vous allez découvrir son
visage dans quelques instants maintenant
regarder
[Musique]
voilà emmanuel macron élu président de
la république
voilà c'est donc et madame la con qui a
gagné ce soir l'élection présidentielle
c'est incroyable ovni dont on parlait on
voit les chiffres 1 les pourcentages
j'avais mal et le maquereau qui obtient
donc 65,1 % des voix à marine le pen
34,9 % des voix un autre chiffre colons
commentera tout à l'heure ses 8,8 pour
cent pour les votes blancs et nuls
arnaud voilà la fête évidemment au
carrousel où les militants
tenant un drapeau français sont déjà sur
la place près de la pyramide il y a de
la joie et le bonheur il y aura près de
dix mille personnes ce soir attendu
emmanuel macron viendra bien sûr les
rejoindre d'abord un premier commentaire
une première réaction les vos quêtes il
ya cinq minutes qui n'était pas encore
élu c'est une estimation évidemment
parce qu'il faudra attendre les chiffres
définitifs et consolider mais tout de
même si ce chiffre reste à 65 1% et un
débat dans l'entre-deux tours s'il passe
sous la barre des 60
ce sera un mauvais résultat pour les
questions les raisons qu'on évoquait 65%
c'est un septième victoire aux résultats
bien sûr c'est une victoire large dont
emmanuel macron peut se réjouir
c'est le deuxième président le mieux élu
par rapport aux suffrages exprimés sous
la vème république jacques chirac avait
été mieux élu avec 80 2 2% contre le
père de marine le pen mais c'est une
victoire large et surtout c'est une
dynamique électorale assez
impressionnante du premier au second
tour rappelant que le même emmanuel
macron rassembler 24 % des suffrages
exprimés
là il atteint 65% c'est une dynamique
importante ça veut dire qu'il a gagné à
peu près je crois entre les deux tours
11 millions d'électeurs alors que marine
le pen a dû en gagner entre 3 et 14 n'a
pas le temps donc